hey guys welcome back to
big mood hi today we have one of our
most favorite returning guests actually
probably our favorite returning guest
because you've been on more than anybody
else i think casey [ __ ]
yes love her so much we love her hi guys
i didn't get to be in the last couple
episodes with you on it so
i'm excited personally like thanks
excited
thank you for inviting me back yeah time
and time again yes i love you here
the audience loves you you have so much
good stuff to say thank you gel really
well yes
thank you yeah so many people comment
like can you guys get stacy do you have
back get stacey
oh yeah they're all nice
i'm like weirdo
[Laughter]
one thing we love about stacy though is
she does a lot of self work
she's really smart with like healing and
everything and so this
episode today i wanted to talk about
codependency
and i know that you've you've been
really good with talking about
attachment styles and all kinds of
relationship things and healthy
relationships and trying to build
healthy relationships yeah
so i definitely wanted to get into
codependency today because i've been
dealing with that
now that i've been single for a year um
i've
what for those gina thank you of course
we're gonna describe it and define it
okay i'll get there gina hands down
i understand things i feel left out
right now we're just going to move along
you're being really codependent right
now
you're exhibiting behavior um no i'm
just kidding
so um what i've realized though is that
i i
previously had a lot of codependent
habits my last relationship
i don't think i had any codependent
habits but then now that i'm single
dating again
some of them are cropping back up so
this is something that i have to go back
and
dig it out and work on this a lot more
yeah and i'm
i'm comfortable now with saying without
shame that i do have
issues with codependency and i feel like
that's something that we should
be allowed to say because i think a lot
of times people are afraid
to admit that they might be co-dependent
it's hard to admit especially when we
all see each other as like really strong
independent
women and you pride yourself on that but
then
when you look at your behaviors in your
relationships you're like oh [ __ ] like
yeah i did that oh i did that oh [ __ ] i
i was codependent yeah
and then i mean in our my relationship
now i haven't been
but in my previous ones i definitely was
and also i um talked to my therapist
because
i guess you know codependent behavior um
i i would seek out
narcissists like yeah um it like thrives
off each other like the narcissist likes
a people-pleaser
and the people-pleaser likes to be a
people-pleaser and then they both
get well let me go ahead and define yeah
we'll get there gina can you she can't
elevate her music yeah
you have it okay i have no idea what
that is i am perfect in every way
it's just so i took notes guys i
actually prepared for this episode i
took notes because this is actually
work that i'm doing in my personal life
anyway like i'm stuck at home
i'm [ __ ] sad as [ __ ] and i'm working
on myself in reading books so yes i have
notes don't make fun of me we don't have
to read all of them but we
love them there's like three pages of
notes here
i freaking love notes i'm here for it
let's go this is the definition well
this is a definition right um this says
codependency is characterized by a
person belonging to a dysfunctional
one-sided relationship
where one person relies on the other for
meeting nearly all of their emotional
and self-esteem
needs and it also describes a
relationship that enables
another person to maintain irresponsible
addictive or unachieving behaviors
yes so did you get that do you want like
the
an example the friend version yeah okay
so if i had to
describe codependency i would say a
person
who disregards their own needs and
feelings for the person they love
oh yes so it's like selling yourself out
yeah so if we were in a relationship
and i was like oh i wanted to go watch
this movie but because you want to go
see a baseball game then we're going to
go see the baseball game who gives a
[ __ ] about me as long as you're happy
i'm happy
my happiness is only through you see so
maybe a more healthy relationship would
be more compromised
yeah this one's more like just it's
always like you're kind of always like
selling yourself out like yeah you never
really get what you need got it okay
thank you
elevator has arrived we're here you're
on the floor i'm on the floor
i'm here so um what i noticed was um
i've so i've had three
actual relationships that were very
codependent and the the original
definition of codependency came from
someone who
was with an addict so it started a lot
of people
assume that they're not codependent
because their husband or wife is not an
addict but the the definition is
actually expanded to someone who's just
like really needs that other person to
feel happy kind of uh is it also
is it also like people two people who
literally have to do everything together
no that's more like people who are like
obsessed with each other like
when she's talking about like it comes
from an addict a lot of times
when somebody's an addict then they go
to rehab for example and
they go through therapy everybody in the
family of the addict
has a role right so for example let's
say we have this family
and the mom is the codependent of the
son
because no matter what the mom finds
happiness through her son and she
enables him
to find drugs she gives him money to
find drugs
she won't kick him out of the house
she's the biggest enabler like the
co-dependent is the number one enabler
of the addict
but like just said now it goes into a
narcissist relationship where the
narcissist is like
like it's about me like how do you think
i feel like if you tell people i cheated
on you
that makes me look bad and the
codependent's like i can never tell
anyone again because it makes him look
bad even though i'm
freaking suffering yeah okay got it
gotcha thank you
you're so good at that friend version
yeah yeah
you've been like you know it's like um
when um
[Music]
it's like uh so uh so me personally i've
been in three relationships with addicts
the very first one uh yeah i got a type
they like drugs
uh and i think obviously it comes from
my mom being an addict right
um but one thing that this year this so
i had a breakthrough okay
yeah we love break through yeah i
always blamed like my mom for [ __ ] and
like obviously like at this point now
i'm old enough i gotta take
responsibility for my own [ __ ] right
yeah
but we do know like some trauma and like
some behavior stem from childhood and
i'm like
it was always my mom my mom my mom she
was the addict she was the [ __ ] up one
but then this year i actually came to
terms with the fact that i do
notice that my dad was also emotionally
unavailable even though he was
physically
available and he was also like he took
care of me he did everything for me he
like he provided everything but there so
i basically had two parents that were
emotionally unavailable
and so that's why like every single
relationship that i seek out is
for some someone emotionally unavailable
because i'm like
trying to like finally yeah make it work
like
oh this one has the same behavior but
this time i'm gonna i'm gonna
fix it and make it work you know so i
follow that behavior but yeah i've had
three relationships with
actual addicts and then i've dated
several people that were into drugs or
had alcohol issues
so it's like wow that's quite a pattern
yeah quite a pattern it's good for you
to
that you like noticed it like a lot of
people don't even make that first step
of like
noticing what pattern they've had in
order to break it acknowledging what's
crazy is that i've also had three other
relationships
that were not with addict addict people
at all they were like with people that
don't drink or
drugs or anything like so i keep
thinking like throughout the years i'm
like oh i'm over that
and then that relationship ends and then
i wind up into it again so it's like a
three or five year cycle
so something is happening where i
actually haven't
completely fixed it because i still am
exhibiting those behaviors but
have you ever considered so i
know that a lot of times when someone
does go to rehab
did your mom ever uh she was clean for a
while i don't think she went to rehab
but she was clean for a little while
so a lot of times when people go to
rehab the family also has to get therapy
with the addict or the alcoholic or
whatever the case may be
so a lot of times the family especially
the person
who is the biggest enabler the
codependent
they have to say you know how like when
an alcoholic goes to a meeting they're
like
my name is whatever and i'm an alcoholic
the codependent there's also codependent
meetings yeah
it's like al-anon or something like that
yeah i don't really know that like right
terminals
are like children of alcoholic parents
yeah so i mean i don't think it's just
you
like oh i'm just crazy and like i have
to break the pattern like your case is
not just
exclusive to you and you might find some
comfort in knowing that you're not the
only one
and that there's other people like you
because i think like how
nikki was saying like oh it's good that
you acknowledge it you know
i always find comfort in knowing it's
not just me crying
for no reason like it's not just me
thinking about oh my god like my
boyfriend's gonna do this on that like
when i
find other girls i feel the same way i'm
like friends like
let's talk about understand yeah you
feel less crazy you know so
have you ever considered like seeking
therapy like for
that specific problem alone yeah yeah so
i've gone i've been in and out of
therapy pretty much my entire life
um so i don't know why i still like
follow some of the same patterns maybe
it's like my ego thinking like
well you're figured it out now or yeah
you're human sometimes you can logically
get something
it takes a lot to like actually yeah
drain it because
that a lot of things that you developed
were probably coping mechanisms when you
were a baby and you didn't even
know you were yeah a lot of this is very
subconscious because like very
consciously i'll be dating and i'll be
like
oh like how often do you drink or how
much do you like to party and i'll like
try to weed things out like in a super
chill way but then like i'll still wind
up
finding myself so magnetic to the you
know the wrong one
but anyways uh i wanted to go over some
symptoms too um
so for girls and and yeah like we said
this codependency thing is not
just like for with someone that's an
alcoholic or a drug addict like this
encompasses other types of relationships
but if you are codependent you might
have some of these symptoms which i do
such as controlling behaviors reactive
emotions obsessive thoughts
problems with intimacy painful emotions
and depression
those are some of the ones that i have
there's also other ones like low
self-esteem
caretaking poor boundaries people
pleasing
not being able to enjoy any interest
outside of your partner like you have to
do everything with them like you don't
want your own hobbies
like you just like the thought of like
taking a weekend without them
scares the [ __ ] out of you um also a lot
of people that are codependent too may
even have their own addictions
um to deal with as well normally the
codependent
their drug of choice is the person
yeah the person they're addicted to yes
for me uh the people pleasing aspect i
like that part was the huge part and i
think the
reason i kept oh by the way
the codependency narcissism relationship
narcissism is hard to break like that's
something
they have that like forever they can
work on it but they like they have that
codependency is a behavioral pattern
that you can break
um if you work on it so i before i was
working on it before i even knew that
that's something that i was doing i
did get in a lot of relationships with
narcissists and
it wasn't that it wasn't like i needed
to be with them at all times because
i've always like
been like an i'm independent you know
but it was that
i was getting with people that would
be inconsistent with the amount of love
they were giving me so
um sometimes they were moms yeah and
then they would withdraw
and then like it was like oh no i like i
lost their approval or like
and and that went back to childhood of
wanting a parent's approval getting
inconsistent love
um thinking that your love was only
given based off of things that you were
doing
and not off of just being and that was
something i had to really relearn
or unlearn that and then relearn like
healthy
things um but yeah i noticed that i
because with steve i'm not like this i'm
not like
constantly needing to like people please
and and and he's gonna be with him with
his love very consistent
and he loves me for me it's
unconditional it's healthy it's very
like
we have space we have boundaries we come
together it's no one's needing anything
from each other
we love it yeah it's great and i hope
everyone finds that
um me too but in my past relationship it
was like
he'd he'd be there and it was like oh my
gosh she's so in love when we love
each other and like it's it's so big and
so powerful and then he
would withdraw for like a long ass time
and i'd be like oh no i lost it and i
just need your fiction again i could to
like get it back like what am i doing
wrong maybe it's my hair maybe it's
oh i need to dress sexier maybe i need
this or that and it was everything to
try to please him to
to gain that love back and the more it
slipped into that the less attracted he
was to me like it
started to slip down that slope and then
the more i would like
try for like the praise and so i've done
that cycle over and over and over and
over and over and over
it drains yourself every relationship um
well with the ones that were unhealthy
so i've had several
unhealthy ones that were like that and
then the ones that weren't like that i
wound up just not really feeling
anything for them
like you're it's almost like you're like
well you i don't have to chase you like
why am i with you heroin i don't want
coffee
you know and it's like those
relationships were serving me coffee
which is just
like a light little buzz but i needed
the [ __ ] hardcore [ __ ]
and that's like what and i would just be
obsessive over it
yeah yeah and then with with the
narcissistic
relationship like the more i'm trying
then they're like oh that's like
yeah you're being shitty and then they
because they like
i think want you to they do i think they
want it's weird yeah
oh narcissistic relationship it gives me
like ptsd yeah
it's a little creepy yeah but yeah but
that's totally how it felt
um relationship addiction is a big part
of that i actually have a note on that
it is
similar to physical addiction i've
actually like i've had some
moments where like i physically felt
like i was withdrawing like my body
like felt so sick i couldn't sleep i
couldn't eat like it the relationships
will get you to a place where you're so
physically sick like i lost a whole
bunch of weight at one point after a
relationship didn't work out i think
we're all looking at you like [ __ ] we
all did like
we can relate yeah so i mean but this to
me like i had to go and get
like [ __ ] prescribed ativan for like
three days so that i could like
come down like from from this like
psycho feeling that
like i just couldn't like i would try to
sleep and then my brain would wake me
back up like it would
wake me back up to think about it yeah
yeah like you sit there
make up things in your head and you're
like what the [ __ ] and then you have to
talk yourself down from it yeah
i get it it's like such a desperate
feeling yeah it really is
and you feel like you can make up for it
somehow or like maybe you missed a step
or you missed a whole yeah
something it's so weird because i'm
obsessive over like how to fix it
it's really frustrating because it's
like you know
that if you you know that it's not right
and if you act on it you know it's going
to be detrimental to the relationship
but you still want to do it anyways yeah
yeah there's been many times where like
the relationship's not going well i see
that it's unhealthy
i should let it go but i keep forcing it
it's almost like i think that eventually
it's gonna work out
and you think you're never gonna find
that feeling with anyone else yeah like
that's really how it felt was like
no this this is so strong that i know
like i have to make this work somehow
do you still feel that way i've i've
run into those feelings again this year
so i know that it's something that i
still have to
deal with yeah because i could i could
relate to those feelings of like
oh my god i'm never gonna find that
again like i love him so much but even
now we're
i'm in a healthy relationship and we
love each other
and we have boundaries and we're there
for each other
i would be so [ __ ] sad if it ever
went the wrong way but i know that
there's someone else that will love me
and i never have that in mind like even
other relationships like where i hear
talk about you and steve like it sounds
like such a beautiful relationship i see
you i see him and i'm like dude that's
dope
but i do you believe that this is the
only thing that you could ever be happy
with well i think
because i've already set my mind on like
he's my forever
like i i don't even go into any other
realms um
but no if i if it really came down to it
like of course i think
it is about self-love it's like you're
still lovable yeah yeah
he's not there even if he's not the one
loving him
that the amount of love you have for
yourself is what you attract back
for sure yeah with them it's tough
though because i almost feel
co-dependent that their relationship
stays together i'm like
the only one that's gonna love you that
much right if you guys ever break up
you're the only one you're the only one
that's gonna love him that much right
but see like even for you to feel that
way about their relationship
like you like are recognizing those
patterns because you're like no no
that's the only love that's available
for you
which it's a beautiful love and we're
not making minimizing it at all
whatsoever
but like nikki is nikki without steve
and steve steven steve without nikki and
then they just happen to have a great
relationship
but even if like god forbid something
were to happen
they would still live on it would be
completely painful but
there are two people that are choosing
to stay together you know
so when it's interesting because when i
was younger i thought like that but now
that i kind of grew up i'm like
not grow up but that i've developed
different parts of myself
i don't feel that way anymore so it's
almost like what is it
in your heart it's weird it's like um
and each time that it happens and then i
like fall for someone else like a month
or year
months or years later and i don't feel
that like obsessive
feeling about the person before it goes
away and i'm like oh well this one's so
much better
but i keep forgetting that next time it
it could be better again it's like i'm
still stuck in the moment
of like no this is this is it like this
this one has
the nine out of ten things that i want
the last one only had eight out of ten
or seven out of ten
so i'm never going to get a 10 out of
10. so this this one has to be the one
but then that goes away and then like as
time goes by i'm like
oh i didn't need that you know but it's
like i keep forgetting in the moment
yeah to where i'm like clinging yeah for
me it was that like i thought i would
never find somebody that understood me
like because i feel like there's only a
few people that i've gotten close enough
to that
they get my bad moments and my good
moments and like they just like
understand me and that was so important
and even though
my ex was treating me shitty um or would
have like weird inconsistent i don't
love you i only only would love you if
you do this
like behavior i was like but they get me
so well so how could they be
they can't be wrong you know and so i
give more trust into
like their opinion or view of me or like
them
doling out the love than me doling out
my own love or
um my opinion of myself and actually
steve really helped me
um like love who i am like
actually helped me grow in that
direction so um
yeah i don't know like it's just uh for
getting out of
that pattern was um really having to
like set boundaries in my own self of
like
this is my pattern of what ends up
happening in a relationship
and these are the flags and i just can't
let it cross this point because once you
let one
one pattern gets started like it just it
snowballs
and so like the whole inconsistent
texting back or inconsistent um with the
way that he feels
about me um it's just a no it's a red
flag i'm not gonna
put up with it anymore and i feel like i
got tested after i
came to that conclusion i went on a few
dates where
i would have gone for those guys like i
was like that
you're my type let's make it happen and
then they threw up the first flag and i
was like
ready to ignore it i was like but i like
all this other stuff about them
like oh i gotta set these boundaries i
think that's what i've been doing now is
i've been getting tested
you know this past year like when we
were still able to date and stuff like i
definitely like really wanted to hang on
to this one guy like so
hard um but but i
you invited other people to come to you
yeah like like you know what i'm the
food delivery guys
you know what i'm dependent on what are
you dependent on dependent
on doordash yeah that's a healthy
dependency
if you have to eat without them i would
literally die
especially during covid right now
doordash is a food delivery service that
i love so much
uh if you're a sack of crap like i am
and you don't ever want to leave the
house
or cook then doordash is your best
friend be codependent on doordash
um the sponsor's gonna be like wait no
wait wait wait wait wait
i love you please tell uh so give
yourself one less thing to worry about
and let doordash take care of your next
meal
doordash is the app that brings food
that you're craving right now right to
your door
ordering is easy open the doordash app
choose what you want to eat and your
food will be left safely outside your
door
with a new contactless delivery drop-off
setting you can support your local
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like
chipotle wendy's what do you see
the cheesecake factory every time a
picture
like i can't open it because
um many of your local favorite
restaurants are still open for delivery
and they
they need your support right now because
of what's going on with this pandemic
just open up the app and select your
favorite local restaurant your food will
be left at your door
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 doll hairs or
more
when you download the doordash app and
enter the code big
mood that's five dollars off and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter the code big mood
don't forget that's big mood for five
dollars off
your first order doordash i love you
you're so cute have you guys ever wanted
to feel like it's christmas for no
reason whatsoever yes
yeah and if your love language is
gifting like mine man have i got
something for you
fabfitfun is a women's lifestyle
subscription box filled with a full-size
premium beauty lifestyle fitness home
and wellness products sent straight to
your doorstep
each season i love it they take the
hassle out of shopping by doing it for
you
each box is customized to your specific
interest and they deliver the seasonal
must-haves
you need the box sell out so fast so
sign up for yours today
i got my first one and i had no idea
what was going to be in it i thought it
was just going to be like those small
little things
it was a huge box yeah yeah all of us
got i love the jewelry they put in those
two like i always get introduced to new
jewelry designers and stuff and it's
always
such cute stuff this year this week or
this season was a
chain oh yeah yeah i did you were in a
present
video yeah i did do that i got a
necklace we're twinsies because i got
the same one hell you saw that
um but yeah like they have everything i
got a i got a full backpack
yeah yeah right like they said so many
things it's so funny
and they tell you the retail value of
each item too in a magazine and i see
like you see what
other people might might have gotten and
you compare and you go i've been getting
fab fit fun
all of all of 2019 i got all the four
seasons of those boxes too and i love it
that's how i got introduced to the whey
hair care i think that's how you say it
oh yeah oh you and i got some really
cute sunglasses in there too
so i love it and then the things that
you maybe don't want there's which
really is very
rare that i don't actually want
everything in the box maybe one or two
things out of the like 10 things that
are in the box i might be like well i'm
not super excited about this
it's super giftable because it's yeah
it's full-size products it's not some
you know bs little samples so i love
it's useful it's time to customize your
box for the fall season sign up today to
receive your first box and join a
community of over one million women
who are already obsessed use coupon code
big mood
for ten dollars off your first box at
www.fabfitsfun.com
again use code big mood for 10 off your
first
box at www.fabfitfun.com
okay but anyways um i and back to the
relationship addiction thing it also
goes into
um actual addictions too there's this
thing um it says
many people are addicted to alcohol and
drugs but don't realize it because
they're still high functioning really
relationship addiction can be the same
like it's easy to not realize that you
have relationship addictions or that
it's not normal
to be experiencing these like high
anxiety states or like these obsessive
states because you kind of just like
we've normalized
um that kind of behavior yeah um but but
one thing that i realized was that like
an obsession with the other
is a distraction from yourself so i
haven't
been able to fully come to terms with
who i am so i think that's why
i do this behavior is because i'm not
fully loving myself it's so much easier
to just like
put my focus on something else i gotta
make this guy love me blah blah versus
just me loving me
yeah i almost feel like i was gonna ask
you earlier do you think
you are worthy of love
i think consciously yes subconsciously
no
yeah because it almost seems like you're
like i
have to gain the love of the person and
if it's not a challenge then i don't
want it right because what's the point
because there are people that do want to
love me and i [ __ ] toss them to the
side
yeah and like even i was actually i just
so the other day
are you are you guys on tick tock yes
okay so not for long girl okay well let
me tell you
so there's this like trying on tech talk
that basically like a bunch of people
did a transgression uh
meditation are you familiar so basically
it's this like guided meditation on
youtube and
everybody was like oh my god you guys i
did this so i tried it right so
basically it's this professor or author
i don't remember
the transcendental meditation or
transgression meditation like you go to
the past
oh i don't know if my english is failing
me but you basically
travel back to your past life regression
regression
there you go there you go yes so
basically it talks about how you go back
to your past lives or whatever and
through the meditation you guys should
really do it it was so
intense it was beautiful yes well
one of the things that he takes you
through in the meditation before he
takes you to your past lives
it's the moment when you were born and
so i don't know if
people listening believe in this or if
you guys believe in this
but i personally really believe in
meditation and so basically he takes you
above the scene of when you were born
and like who was there
how did your parents feel look at your
mom's face look at your dad's face
like you know if your parents were i
mean if your dad was or not and
one of the things he takes note of that
you think about is
you were loved without even trying you
didn't have to do anything
like just the fact that you're human
means that you need love
a human being not a human trying yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm doing
yeah yeah get it right gina yeah
that was really touching for me because
like of course you think about that
you're like yeah i deserve love
like i everybody should love me just
because i'm human but actually
feeling yeah like you didn't have to do
anything you were just a baby
and your mom loved you your dad loved
you
and you were just sitting there like not
even knowing what the hell is going on
and feeling that as a grown-up not
necessarily like oh my parents love me
but i deserve love just because i exist
yes
yeah that was very powerful i think like
not doing the
regression uh thing but i did in therapy
i did do um some sort of meditation
where
i did like a re-parenting thing so it
was like i had to visualize being a
little girl in a kind of a traumatic
moment that i remember because i was
left alone a lot
too those weren't the traumatic parts
but those are the parts that stick with
me was just the feeling alone part two
because i was always left alone as a
little child so i remember she had me
kind of visualize myself in my bedroom
alone because she would always be gone
getting [ __ ] up
and then so i she had me then visualize
myself now my adult self now with my two
dogs
walking into that room with that little
girl who was just by herself and scared
and then and immediately it clicked to
me i was like i'm okay now
yeah like i have myself like like that
little girl that was scared and felt
alone
is like she's really not anymore she's
not helpless she's not anything like and
like i feel good about i felt good
like watching my adult self now go into
that room and be like hey do you want to
play with the dogs like
so it's like a similar thing like
re-parenting whatever it is that you
feel like you missed out on
i saw a tick tock um where this girl was
like i want you to think about
your most it's like that your most
traumatic moment when you were a kid
and then imagine yourself now as an
adult going in there and just hugging
yeah that's um so it's very common in
therapy
when you meditate into your it's like
child work like because the person that
you were when you were
a child still lives within you yeah and
so all those questions i'm sure you've
talked about this in therapy all those
questions
that you had when you were like where's
my mom why am i by myself i'm scared
like somebody walked by whatever all
those thoughts were always left on
answer and so you grew up and you're
like well i'm fine now yeah
you're fine now but it's important to
meditate and go back to those moments
and reassure yourself now and
let her know i'm here with you i don't
know if you guys believe in like
different dimensions
like all your life yes
i love it so your whole life is
basically going on in different
universes at all times right so when you
meditate you jump into different
years of your life oh that's dope yeah
so even when you meditated
and you went back into your childhood
bedroom yeah that truly was you visiting
yourself and taking care of yourself
from that like a strangely
relieving to see like that little girl
to see who i am now
that i'm okay that i have these two like
cute-ass little dogs that are just
running around
and you were there with yourself and it
it's even comforting to think
that in these moments when life is tough
as grown-ups now
future us can hangs out with us at some
point like you you're not aware of it
but
i'm sure in the tough moments of my life
my future self has came by
and been like you got it like maybe we
are our own guardian angels
yeah in a way because your future
dead self is like looking down on it
yeah yeah or even like 50 year old
like jess is married with children and
she's like ooh girl like she's like
you're fine
yeah but your feelings are still valid
yeah yeah yeah yeah so one of the
meditations i do
recently um like when i'm going through
just like
how everything's like the shit's hitting
the fan right now
um one of the meditations i did was like
imagining yourself
five or ten years from now and like what
your ideal version of yourself is and
imagine what does she look like
does she have kids what's her day like
like what does she do for work
like just imagining every detail of who
this person is
and then she comes and sits down with
you and like
like tell tells you answers any
questions you need to know
and like you just have this whole like
meeting with her and then
me now feels good like oh she's
she's fine you feel guided you yeah yeah
like you pan out from like this moment
where
everything's breaking down and you're
like we lived through it though
like it wasn't so horrible that we
didn't make it through
yeah and maybe like for those maybe if
you've never tried meditating you're
like this is very woo-woo
i mean just try it with an open mind
because like
nobody knows we don't know yeah even if
it's placebo effect like let's say it
works
fake and it's placebo effect well even
medically it works so if you're a
logical person then you should
believe in placebo effect anyway yeah i
sound like tic-tac-toe this is [ __ ]
dumb
but i'm gonna do it before morning four
in the morning i'm gonna do it anyways
like you know you're [ __ ] crying well
i do have some stuff on like how to heal
from it but i think the biggest thing is
is just recognizing it first of all and
like not being ashamed of it because i
think a lot of times people hear
codependent or they hear
something and they're just like oh
that's not me or like oh that's
embarrassing or like
the denial part of that or they blame
men yeah they they
blame other outside things like i just
there's just no decent guys or whatever
so question though how can people
because like
we are here and we're like okay this is
a definition it's easy
but for example when i'm listening to
things like this or when i'm watching i
tend to be like oh my god i'm
codependent like
just because i have one of the two
symptoms yeah like i'm like i'm
definitely co-dependent like i'm gonna
die you know so what's the difference
between a normal girl who wants to spend
time with her boyfriend and see him and
hang out
and like if he's being a like if he's
being rude and like she's upset like
what's the difference yeah like how do
you notice happy behavior
and somebody that's like a codependent
well i think the best thing to do
because each person is so different and
their life is so different
and there's so many variables would be
like you could actually go in and
get a book on codependency and like
they'll really [ __ ] break it down
if you feel it's hard to break it down
like within just a few minutes right but
then
there's just a lot of things like do you
are you okay when he's gone are you okay
yeah um like just even thinking about
leaving the relationship would that
actually completely [ __ ] crush you
or would you be like oh i'd be sad but
like it's okay or like do you feel
also do you feel like you're not being
taken care of do you feel unfulfilled
do you feel desperate like do you feel
unhealthy you feel sad all the time
if because of your relationship but then
you're like wait no but i love them
are they doing things to disrespect you
and you just overlook it like there's
just like you've got to be able to
distinguish like
um things that are just disrespectful
and not right or unfulfilling like
yeah i think at the bottom of it all
like even hearing you talk i'm like oh
my god let me
i'm listening like am i codependent you
know but even here you talk like
the bottom of it all i always think to
myself i love me more than i love
everyone else and not in like an
egotistic way like oh who gives a [ __ ]
about you guys feelings like not like
that but in a way that's like
i love my partner i i'm in love with him
and i respect him
but if he ever did something that made
me doubt myself worth or made me
doubt my love for myself i would be
willing to walk away from that
so i don't think that you're a
co-dependent right right yeah
because like for me well now i think i'm
actually getting much better because i
did walk away from
a guy that i was dating that it just
started getting unhealthy and i was like
this is something when i was 22. i would
have [ __ ] stayed in it
um but yeah so like i used to stay like
my ex would would be cheating constantly
like and just right in front of my face
like it was just so blatantly
unfulfilling and disrespectful and i
would just make excuses for it and stay
because i didn't want to be alone um so
that was like
kind of a good way it was pretty awesome
yeah like a lot of people can have
behaviors or just
seasons where they kind of act a little
bit codependent but i think overall it's
just like
oh this reminds me i went to therapy um
like my best therapist that i ever went
to that broke down all this stuff for me
that sent me a link
definitely um she's expensive but she
has like a program that you're done
instead of ongoing forever she has like
a program that like she's called the
mind map and she
she specializes in codependent
narcissistic relationships but
she like you reprogram like all the
stuff that you wired in your brain when
you were a baby and like didn't know and
like you
it's really great anyway um i went to
her
because even though i wasn't
experiencing that in my relationship
i realized i was having the same sort of
feelings um towards like
my audience as a as a youtuber oh yeah
yeah yeah even in girl friendships or
guys yeah it can be in like a number of
things that you
you can have like unhealthy if people
were um like
disappointed in me or they didn't like
if i changed
my format or whatever i would try to
cater to everybody
like where i was like oh well i'm not
really satisfied doing these types of
videos anymore i was wanting to do these
more types of videos but then
this sector of people was mad like oh i
did cooking videos right and then there
was a time where i changed to doing
plant-based cooking because
personally i stopped eating meat and
then it felt weird cooking with me even
if i wasn't eating meat but i didn't
want to shove my beliefs on anybody but
anyway i just transitioned into just
making plant-based meals because that's
what i was doing for me
and there was a lot of hate of people
that like
were pissed that i stopped cooking with
me and and i was like
i was freaking out inside and i know
it's like looking back now i'm like
that's not a big deal like why
did you freak out so much but internally
i was having panic attacks all the time
because i was like
should i cook with me just for those
people and like i was going crazy and
it was over something minor like that
and then it started leaking into just
other areas of like
any criticisms people had of me of
and you know the more your audience
grows the more criticisms you're gonna
get
um i was just like i can't do anything
right like i'm [ __ ] up like everyone
hates me everyone's going to hate me and
became obsessive so that goes back into
the yeah where one person relies on the
other whether that's
one person or your whole audience to
meet nearly all of their emotional
self-esteem needs like if you felt
emotionally strong in yourself and you
had all the self-esteem in the world you
wouldn't give a [ __ ] you're like i don't
care if you want meat i'm not cooking
with meat anymore yeah yeah
which is like now i'm i'm there
i'm like this is me you do you i do me
whatever
but yeah it went back to child because i
didn't think of it outside of a
romantic relationship as having
co-dependent issues but
since that same those same feelings
started coming back and it felt like
i was in an abusive relationship again
basically just not with steve
um i yeah it went back to all of those
issues
as a child it always goes back to
childhood i feel like um your
psychological
issues and like you i was always like
opposite though focused on my dad like
oh
dad dad dad issues um but those got
resolved and then like
there were certain things that um i felt
like my mom at the time had to
had to carry like had to shoulder
everything and
maybe there were times where i because
she was working full-time that i just
wanted my mom and she was working she
wasn't doing drug shoes but she had to
provide for a family and you know and i
just
uh that same environment of like you not
getting your
needs met when you're really small as a
kid you can still create that same
exactly because as an adult i'm like
well she had to do that she had to
provide for family
like i can logically be like i would
have done the same thing time with my
dad it's like
right it wasn't emotionally available
enough but it's like not for a bad
reason it's like no just circumstantial
but as a kid
you are as a very little kid like you
don't differentiate that you're just
like
my mom's not here i need my mom like i
need love i need my mom and she's not
here
i think uh you touched on something
earlier that kind of sparked a memory in
my head where you said that
you know that you're gonna be okay even
after a breakup
i i think that's something because for
me somebody told me that before
and then i realized that's something
really hard to hear from your partner
because
um we were innocent they told you what
like i'm gonna be fine after you he said
um
if we break up i'm going to be sad for a
little while but at the end i'm going to
be okay
and then yeah that's hard to hear me
it's really hard it stings it stinks to
me it's just like no
i want you to [ __ ] die if i leave you
you know and i was like wait no that's
not right because it's not healthy
yeah i think the same way too i'm like
if we break up i'm gonna be so sad but
i'm gonna be okay you know yeah but it's
really hard to hear that from someone
that is so crazy to think about because
i i'm the one that's like i'm gonna be
fine
you know and so i don't know that i've
ever
even like when i was stupid in love not
that i'm still
super in love but when i was young
and more naive you know i was still like
you know like i could still i'll i'll be
fine yeah you're such an aries
yeah yeah exactly i am yeah if you're a
guy
if you were a guy i would be making you
fall in love with me right now because i
would want it so bad
probably because your hair was so great
but yeah so i had like when i first
heard that i was like excuse me
and then how dare you first of all gina
wasn't it because your hair was so great
and you were like oh wow nikki's trying
so hard to
segue into that you know during that
argument i had great hair
yeah so you were so confident he was
going to be sad to leave you because
your hair was so weird my hair was so
silly yeah
you're like why are the hairless hair
like what's that but we'll get to that
because that is important but first i
want to talk about function of beauty
because it's bomb
and we all love it our hair is uh
thriving on it and also i love how
okay one it's custom i have so many
things i love about this this company
um i even reordered and paid with my own
doll hairs because i
like oh me too i reordered them i loved
it but yeah no this company so it's
everything's custom and so you go on
there
you take a hair quiz they're like what
kind of hair do you have is it straight
is it wavy is it curly with your
thickness is it fine is it thick is it
coarse is it bleached
is it bleached is it color treated they
ask you all kinds of questions about
your hair i'm like natural natural
natural
i know you have virgin hair yeah it is a
virgin
um but it'll get version soon sometime
we'll get there
um but anyway uh yeah you take the hair
quiz and then
it determines like what custom formula
will help your hair thrive the most
according to also your hair goals do you
want more shine do you want more volume
do you want less frizz whatever it is
and then you get to pick the scent
so i currently i did eucalyptus because
i really love eucalyptus but now i'm on
lavender and it's so refreshing and so
distressing
and um and then you get to pick the
color and so i picked purple to go with
lavender just because i'm a visual
person
and then you get to put your they put
your name on the bottle so it's very
very personalized to you if someone else
used your
hair formula it might not work the same
for them but i really like that
personalized
thing and then they deliver it right to
your door
convenient you don't have to even leave
your doorstep
and then you can get on a subscription
if you want to so
what are you waiting for go to
functionalbeauty.com big mood to take
your four-part hair profile quiz and
save 20
on your first order go to
functionofbeauty.com
big mood for 20 off to let them know
that you heard about it from our show
that's function of beauty dot com
slash big move yay
all right now can i talk about cox for a
second fine
our next sponsor is roman we are
codependent on the clock
i like when [ __ ] work i like when they
get really really hard
and if you happen to just have a little
bit of an issue with getting hard roman
can help you boys
you don't need to make any excuses a lot
of men actually deal with erectile
dysfunction it's nothing to be ashamed
of it's natural there's all kinds of
even if you don't have erectile
dysfunction but just like want to stay
harder longer yeah they have they have
more than one product as well but today
we're talking about erectile dysfunction
medication
that they can connect you with a doctor
online
so with roman you get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care for ed all
from the comfort and privacy of your
home you don't have to go look a man in
the face and tell him that your dick
doesn't work
you can do it uh online it's someone
here a healthcare professional will work
with you to find the best treatment plan
if medication happens to be appropriate
roman
will ship it to you with free two-day
shipping it used to be
a tough thing to tackle but now it's
super simple
so go to getroman.com big mood
today if you're approved you'll get 15
off your first order of ed
treatment that is get roman.com
big mood get roman.com big move
take care of it take care of your dicks
yeah we're fixing relationships we're
fixing weiners
we're fixing all kinds of stuff that's
what we do we're fixers have an ideal
life
but don't be a fixer okay don't be a
fixer that's me
so for you guys because you have the
opposite things
that you're saying like you that you're
the person that's like i'm fine
i'm fine and that's the thing i always
said it too i just never said it out
loud out loud
because when i hear it's hurtful i can
pinpoint exactly what hurts me about
that is that it sounds like you're not
as committed as me
yeah like it sounds like one foot out
the
yeah but i mean my point to that is
shouldn't you
always feel not like you have one foot
out the door
but like you're here and you're gonna be
okay here no because we want to be here
yeah like we we love each other so much
true yeah
if you ever are not happy and i'm never
not the best option for you
i respect you and love you enough to
want you to pursue what's best for you
yes that's the love that i want
so maybe i don't know which demeanor you
were told that or like and what the
situation was so but i'm never like
and i don't give a [ __ ] like i'll walk
i'm never like that it's a conversation
that we're having and i'm like
i love you so much and if you feel like
this isn't working for you anymore
because i'm not the best thing for you
i love you and respect you for that i
agree with that
logically if someone's saying
that um like hey i'm gonna be okay it to
me i'm like why are you saying that
because
are you saying that because you're
already feeling like you're about to
walk away and that you're gonna be okay
because otherwise like wouldn't you just
be like i'm so happy to be here right
now
yeah like what you're saying that you're
going to be fine with right
now good you know you're saying hey i'm
going to be fine without you this is a
comic book
all right god damn it i don't know
attack
fire sign but i don't know why this is
working out right now maybe
yeah i think maybe i just like for all
we know you guys are just like perfectly
fine and i'm just like
the one that's not committed or whatever
but because of the way i grew up you
know
but the way i see it is with these
conversations that just happen like i'm
walking in from work and i'm like i can
be fine without you like you know what i
mean
like like i'd be fine without this job
without all this [ __ ] you wake them up
in the middle of the night and i live by
what's the difference between that and
being like not being able to commit if
you're just not attached to anything
well the thing
so i'll tell you my personal difference
i would
marry my boyfriend in a heartbeat i
would be with him forever in a heartbeat
i want to spend a long long time with
him together
uh it's two years and like a month ish
but i was gonna tell you um the thing is
i don't even like using the word forever
because eventually
one of us will pass and it was one of us
our forevers but not the other person
and so
i'm not saying like i'm leaving because
i [ __ ] hate you and i found someone
better or whatever i'm saying like
life happens and you have to know
that at the end of it all you're gonna
be okay regardless of what happens
i don't mean someone's gonna get cheated
on like i will never cheat on anybody
and i live by that and if i ever got
cheated on i will survive like it's not
detrimental to my health or my heart it
will hurt a lot
but i don't necessarily mean like we're
gonna
be unfaithful to each other or find
someone better i just
like a lot of things can happen and it's
just secure basically and it's 100
secure
yeah it gets really dark but like how
many people are widows
yeah and should you not everybody shows
a lot of widowers
yeah like should you not ever get a
chance to
live again and love again because you
devoted yourself like if i passed away i
would want my boyfriend to find someone
to make them happy the best case
scenario like you both loved each other
as much as you could until life
and i were looking down from the heavens
like you better not
the moment you about to [ __ ] some other
[ __ ] i'm gonna come in i'm a
poltergeist
would you do that for him like would you
never [ __ ] anyone else
for the rest of your life are you really
that in love yeah totally
[Applause]
what about me all right we know damn
we're talking about us
yeah it's just i think you have to be
able to
take it if you're going to dish it out
right oh have you what was that
that like kink quiz thing the like um
look at that test yeah okay we both got
brats
yeah we're the same exact person yeah
when it comes to like relationships when
it comes to like
how we like being loved and like um and
then sexually and all that stuff we got
like
submissive brat yeah yeah
so we're like you gotta
[Laughter]
that's pretty cute but yeah so like some
other i guess healing
directions and stuff that i'm working on
um i i did like i i was like how do i
okay how do i get rid of this because
obviously this is my number one thing
like before i get into the next
relationship i mean obviously i'm still
gonna be working on it i might slip and
fall and fall into these patterns again
but
i'm working on it so this is this is
some uh how to heal this is what i found
obviously recognizing the first step um
counseling embracing the honesty of it
um is a big thing i've already been in
counseling for this a lot so i think now
it's just for me it's more like putting
action into kind of like what i've
already known but if you haven't even
started
counseling might be a good step another
thing is like reconnecting with friends
and family because um
like people like me ten tend to get so
like obsessed or wrapped up into
into that relationship or something you
kind of almost start isolating yourself
yeah like you you stop like going out
with your girlfriends and blah blah
until it's over and then all of a sudden
you need them again and and then so it's
just like trying to maintain
always maintain a level of your life
like your friends are always there your
life is kind of always still going
regardless of the relationship and
on that note though having good friends
because like that's hard it's
fine if you have also toxic friends then
they're kind of enablers too they're
they can be if they're like um
like what no he needs to be like this or
whatever and then like stay with your
man
just stay with patterns yeah yeah
she said that to me no but you you okay
because you're
crazy you're an abandoned i'm not crazy
you're trying to abandon him yeah
and he does one [ __ ] title on jess
the past is the past
look look he has nothing he does one
[ __ ] thing wrong and gina's like i'm
[ __ ] leaving his ass he's like
listen you called me and what did i tell
you
you told me a lot yeah yeah right but
like
was she trying to leave him for nothing
okay codependency
let her respect and put her boundaries
i know but but like he takes one small
serious
he does one small thing and she's trying
to run and i'm like those are hair
boundaries
wasn't that small the fear of
abandonment also
causes me to push away relationships
that could be healthy
because i'm like oh wait no to actually
be loved is [ __ ]
blows my mind here's here's where i
think you're both right
and wrong okay okay so this is what
happened when you're not here
so i agree with that
hey if this is my boundary and like you
crossed it stand your ground yeah
this i still believe that but also the
way that gina
stands her ground is not she burns the
healthiest
so i think like have a conversation with
him
maybe not burn the whole [ __ ] house
[Laughter]
i think it's worked very well for me to
be like this is my line and if you want
to cross it
there will be consequences yeah yeah for
that particular issue i don't think i
think it's a subconscious thing that he
was doing
so jess you're both right okay but not
so have boundaries yeah
don't be like have boundaries keep doing
it over and over and over again even
though it really really hurts me it
really bothers me and it's gonna fester
and then
eventually i'm gonna hate you forever
yeah don't do that um but maybe have
a conversation instead of small things
or some patience a little bit of
patience
and a little bit of of letting him grow
because if you just go and attack then
he's going to be on the defense and like
yeah
be like [ __ ] you back when you make a
mistake do you want him to [ __ ] burn
the ground down or do you want
him to give you what kind of mistake are
we talking about right so i think we all
have
our set of individual boundaries and we
all accept what we think is okay to
ourselves or upbringing whatever the
case may be
and if someone like if your best friend
was telling you
hey this is what happened to me what
would you tell her leave him [ __ ] get
another dick
so you you standing broke anyway
but the thing is though they're all
broken
just which kind of broken doll do you
want to play with
we're all broke we're all broken it's
easier to give advice and take it though
that's
for sure for sure especially if you're
in it yeah but you want to you want to
treat yourself like someone you love
right and you love your best friend i
would never tell her to stay in
something that was detrimental
for sure so i don't want it to be like
that i personally think
and this is not speaking to your
specific situation but i think that what
you allow will continue
of course and it will only get worse
yeah that's true so it's like
when you get the first six months of a
relationship i don't know how long it's
been or whatever but
those are like the little appetizers if
you will that you're getting and
eventually the main dish is gonna come
out
so that's what i struggle with because
it's like
how do i know if it's um appetizer
active growth like he's trying to learn
from it or this is going to be like all
right this is not
you know i think you trust you'll trust
yourself and eventually it'll get to the
point where you'll be like
oh that was too much of a main dish for
me like you know what
that's my line and that was good enough
like no one ever knows like i could sit
here and be like break up with him stay
with him or whatever but
you only know your bottom line and how
far you're willing to take it
and when you get there whether it's him
doing whatever or him doing something
worse or maybe someday you'll
literally just wake up and be like like
i'm over it yeah
you know yeah so that's what i struggle
with personally because it's like
where what is um
being uh compromising as opposed to
being walked all over
yeah besides the obvious there's kind of
a thin line yeah
i think intentions really do matter so
um
like his intentions weren't
trying to disrespect you obviously uh
even though you still felt disrespected
if that makes sense so like
for me it would be different if he was
intentionally disrespecting you over and
over and like
trying to make you feel like you're at
fault for that i'd be like it's not
worth it gina leave it like
right boundaries he crossed them many
times by
but if it feels like in your situation
it was
unintentional and he's so he feels
bad about like and he like doesn't want
to keep going and i'm not talking about
a guy that like abuses you or like is it
like there's nothing
it's a certain slight like you know how
you have something that like maybe it
kind of like
irritates you a little bit and like
someone's kind of like pumping like that
and then you're just like stop
[ __ ] poking me and they're like oops
i didn't know i was even touching you
um it's like that there's a line uh i
forget how it goes but it's like
we judge ourselves and our actions based
on our intentions but we just
we judge other people just based on the
action we don't even consider their
intention so it's like
you got to take into account how you
would judge yourself if you made that
mistake too
right a little bit i don't know i don't
know i'm confused by that because i
personally stand my ground when i say
that it doesn't matter how you mean to
do something it's how it comes off so
when i learned the difference between
those two things for example i could be
like
oh my god like i totally didn't mean to
disrespect you that way
but you did so what are you gonna do
about it now like you did disrespect me
and that was
hurtful to me so if you see them taking
accountability then yeah it's easier to
forget
to give forgiveness for sure the first
time yeah and then what
like what do you need to do so it
doesn't happen again because if it's
going to continue to happen then this is
not something that i can continue to put
up yeah i get that
because the first time it's a mistake i
get it it happens
the second time like what why is this
still happening the third fourth fifth
time like why
am i even still tolerating it and the
the the reason is because
you want to and you can because no one's
the
the boss in your life but you you know
but
yeah i think that whole like oh like he
didn't mean to well but he did
so what's the action behind it like how
does he fix it
you know i think us as women we often go
with the whole like oh he didn't mean to
he didn't know any better
but men are grown up like they're
they're grown men and
they should be responsible for their
actions yeah they shouldn't just be like
oh he didn't know any better like
he's a grown-ass man tiff says how do
you maintain the boundary that you set
then
so i'm i could talk for personal
consequences i guess
yeah for sure like for example i
i think i'm gonna get in trouble for
saying this but i'm gonna say it from
who who's gonna get you in trouble well
like i respect my boyfriend my
relationship you know but for i'm just
gonna give a minor example so with the
whole cover thing
we're all learning are different
boundaries like everyone's different
boundaries you're learning
your sisters your partners your moms
whatever whoever you live with
so for example now that things have
loosened up and
things are more like free or whatever my
boyfriend has gone to go get a haircut
for example right
and if that makes me really nervous i'm
like no don't go get a haircut like
please like what if you catch go in and
then you're gonna bring it to the house
whatever
but to him the haircut is so important
right so a boundary i've said with him
is like any time you go out anywhere
that i feel like it's unsafe or you're
like surrounded by too many people or
whatever i don't want to see you for
three to four days
so that's a small boundary compared to
like other things
but i live by that i don't see him for
even if i want to see him and when i've
gone to places like this
where i'm surrounded by people i haven't
seen or whatever the case may be he's
like i don't want to see you for three
to four days
and i'm like okay that's something i can
respect because i was the one who
brought this boundary into our
relationship
so now i have to live by that too well
thank you for sacrificing three or four
days without your boyfriend to come see
us
you're welcome no i'm just kidding he's
not that strict with it like i am
you know but uh that's an example of a
boundary and you can set boundaries with
anybody like my sister and i have
boundaries with each other
we live together and it's like don't
bring anything outside of your room like
a mess
you know that you because it's a
personal space like i mean the
common space between everybody and if we
do
for example we clean each weekend like
i'll clean should clean and if one
person doesn't clean on their weekend
like we have to pay up 50 bucks
oh smart yeah so that's the boundary
that we've set and we
follow through with it even if it's
[ __ ] hard for you
you have to follow through with your
boundaries the follow-through i think is
hard because like when you're in a
relationship and you're living together
it's like how do you really set
consequences like what do you even do
you're just like mad i'm just now i'm
pissed so what what's the physical thing
that i do
to actually like create the boundary or
to or to
give consequences like what do you even
do i think so like you have to talk
about specific examples yeah like
what's the problem with so like maybe
there's some i don't let's just make
something up so like say
a girl um is dealing with a guy who's
being too flirtatious with someone at
work or something and like every time
you go
bringing lunch at work you're like
what's up why is this [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you know like why are you why are you
not doing something
to set the boundary with her like i feel
disrespected when you're around her like
what's the deal with that but then you
go home and you live together
like how do you even set a boundary with
him or give consequences to him or like
i thank god i've never been in this
situation
but i think anything that a man's doing
if so for example if i was to be in that
situation i would be like
you literally have to either like talk
to her make sure she's respecting you
because i
i'm not gonna go do that you know like
it is your job as my partner who knows
her and knows me
to either send her an email send her a
text speak to her in front of me or
whatever the keys may be like hey
you're crossing a boundary because you
brought me lunch five times a week or
whatever and i don't want you to do that
anymore because my wife will take care
of that you know but
i thought of something else when you
were saying that so for example if your
husband
boyfriend whatever whoever you live with
is always leaving his things around
right like that's probably a common one
like as women we're always expected to
clean after
people when my boyfriend comes over he
knows how like
clean i like my things so if he leaves
something i will not pick it up even if
it kills me
like even if i see it and i'm like oh my
god like that is my one like this is my
bedroom we don't even live together
respect my space when he comes home
i'm like hey can you pick up your things
and he's like oh shoot like i totally
forgot okay thank you like next time and
he's really good at respecting me
because he loves me
i think if you set a boundary and you
express to them how
annoying it is or how painful it is or
whatever the case may be
and they're still doing it like that's
not a matter of a boundary that's a
matter it's going to turn into a main
dish yeah
realize that that person is not
respecting you and once it's a main dish
then do
what's your opinion you leave you always
have to be willing to leave yeah
yeah that's that's i think ultimately
what you
harkens back to what you said in the
beginning was that like you have to know
that you're gonna be okay
and that you're gonna be fine and you
can walk away and you can find someone
that actually i
know how to put the foot out the window
and in your case
too it's like it was multiple boundaries
though so that's the only
reason that i'm like more on the side of
you know
this way or at least like there's got to
be more consequences
or whatever but um it's hard when you're
going through it yeah
but uh but yeah like because it's it's
not
the things being left out that that
you're breaking up the responsibility
the respect and steve was doing stuff
like this in the first year and he
didn't get
because i would respond like with anger
because i was like
why do you keep doing this like i asked
you a million times how to do this
and he didn't he would just put on anger
things that snagging
and then when i finally broke down and
cried one time because
i was just like you don't [ __ ]
respect me like
this is my these are my things and and
when you do this constantly over and
over
even though you know that it hurts my
feelings like
you are basically saying i don't give a
[ __ ] about you yeah and
and so it's not okay for me like and i'm
not we're not breaking it up over
this situation this for me it was a
panda that he kept [ __ ] cutting
his knife from the pan the non-stick
pans and ruining all my pants
it's that you don't have the
consciousness to like
it's like yeah she's gonna [ __ ] pan
yeah and he didn't get that it
hurt me he was like oh she's nagging me
but then when
once he realized like what he was doing
was hurting me and it was causing
resentment because i used that word too
i was like
i'm building resentment against you and
soon enough
there's gonna be a wall like i'm just
gonna be so emotionally detached from
you that
it's not even gonna work anymore and
once he heard that
he was like oh [ __ ] it's a respect thing
it's not about the pants he was thinking
it was about the pants like what it's
just a ten dollar pan what he's probably
like why don't you care so much about a
panda yes
that is what it was and then once he
realized that it is when the behavior
changed and it was like
it never went back again like he never
went and cut in my pants again and
um and anytime anything similar has
happened like that
he knows immediately oh it's a respect
thing not
of this 10 item thing and he loves you
so he respects your boundaries yes
but he will laugh if he was like it
hurts you and i'm going to continue to
cut in these pans
i would have to walk away that's
absolutely disrespectful
well one final thing before we go there
was this little short list of like five
things that i found online this is like
moving forward from codependency
the first one is stop thinking a
relationship is the key to your
happiness
i've i think i've spent a lot of my life
feeling that way like oh once i get the
relationship then i'll be happy but it's
actually like that's just one
piece of your life there's still this
whole other part of your life like don't
ignore the whole rest of your life and i
think i was
guilty of doing that for a while you
happy or not happy
yeah so if you have nothing but waiting
for that relationship
you should not be in a relationship
because you need all of the other stuff
you're fulfilled on your own and they
just
and i kept hearing that i keep hearing
that i'm like one ear not the other
because i don't want to [ __ ] do all
that work you know what i'm saying
so that's what i'm doing now um also
number two stop thinking emotional
intimacy is only possible in a romantic
relationship
so like you have to be able to find
another outlet
friends or something where you can
actually be
emotionally intimate get your emotional
intimacy needs met even if it's
friends or family or something it's not
just your partner's the only person that
you can really open up to
you have to be able to let other people
do that as well
stop refusing to spend time alone if you
don't know who you are when you're alone
for a long period of time
you're constantly influenced by others
and you don't really know who you are so
then how can you pick
a partner that's good for you it's not
possible how can you set boundaries if
you don't know who you are
and then stop putting everything else on
hold when you get into a relationship we
kind of covered that but this one
stop selling yourself short and then the
author said love is not a charity case
and that kind of hit me it was like
love is not a charity case so it's like
you you shouldn't be accepting love from
a man who's kind of just like throwing
you [ __ ] breadcrumbs
like you're not a charity case you're
not lucky that they're [ __ ] putting
up with you or
enough to stay around and i'm just like
yes as soon as i read that i was like oh
[ __ ] like they're doing bare minimum
yeah like why am i
lucky that he's barely showing up [ __ ]
have you seen you have you gotten to
know you
have you ever realized how wonderful you
are
no homework or next time i come over
you better know your damn worth you out
there yes spend some damn time alone
with yourself loving yourself
i actually when i lived alone i hugged
myself a lot because i realized i needed
more
i love that that's one thing i do miss
i'm like i just want a man's arms to
hold me
that's really well that's really kind of
a body pillow no i want a man's arms to
hold me that's all i want
a bath feels like a hug sometimes i take
baths every [ __ ] day sometimes three
times a day because i just need the
warmth and comfort
anyway bye anyway bye
[Laughter]
i just imagine you're sitting in the
corner that is i'm actually in an empty
bathtub
yeah she says
yeah all right thanks guys for watching
uh reyna's five stars please i mean we
need that we're done
on itunes um leave a like leave a
comment go to our instagram at big mood
girls
um that's where we're gonna also be
posting questions for our q
a episodes so follow that watch that
give us some submissions
make sure you follow stacy too yes yes
she's cool her links are stacey
is apodaca
[Music]
yeah this girl's a bad [ __ ] you're not
following her what are you doing one of
my favorite
she's ever said was respect the stallion
because she's a stallion oh
[ __ ] dude that was my favorite tweet
from her because somebody said like oh
women over blah blah blah wait is mom
amendment and she posted a picture of
herself she's like i'm over blah blah
blah respect the stallion i was like oh
here we go yes girl i fell in love am i
a stallion
no nicki you're not a stallion yes we
have a clown
dwarf pony